Well, we're done with
the core of our content provider,
but there's still one more
optional method
that will make things much more efficient.
We'll start by hitting Ctrl+O
to look at the functions we can override.
It turns out there's
a function called bulkInsert.
Anyone out there who
has done database work
knows that putting a bunch of inserts
into a single transaction
is usually much faster
than inserting them individually.
Bulk insert allows us to do just that.
The default implementation
just calls insert a bunch of times,
but we can wrap it in a transaction
if we implement it ourselves.
We're only going to add support
for weather forecast transactions here,
since they're the only ones
we insert in bulk.
We start by calling db.beginTransaction.
For each ContentValues passed in,
we insert and update
the number of records inserted.
When we're done, we set the transaction
to be successful.
Otherwise our records will not be committed,
and then rely on the finally statement
to end the transaction.
In the default case,
we just call the super class.
Remember, it does the insert,
just not optimally.
And that's it.
That's all we have to do
to implement bulkInsert.